So we talked about organizations
as part of their security planning
need to have a security policy.
While Georgia Tech has a computer and
network use policy,
we talked about do's and don'ts.
What is okay to do, and
what you should not do.
So let's quickly sort
of look at some things
that are there in the Georgia Tech
computer and network use policy.
It does articulate, it does talk about
what some of the guiding principles are.
Why does the policy
look the way it does?
First of all, we want the policy guiding
principle is that we want in order to
protect important IT resources
that Georgia Tech has.
So when you protect, you're
talking about protecting the data,
the services, and things like that
which are enabled by those resources.
Another guiding principle is that we
don't let anything illegal happen that
involves our computer systems,
our IT systems.
So these are the guiding principles,
but you should read the policy.
And here, we're just going to talk about
sort of couple of quick highlights,
things that you might think jump out and
say, why do we have this?
So it talks about copyright and
intellectual property, actually.
So why is it talking about?
Of course, as a research university,
Georgia Tech creates
intellectual property and so
on, and that intellectual property
resides on our computers.
But at the same time, state campuses,
they used to have a problem where
people would download music.
In particular,
they will download illegal music, and
universities got into
trouble because of that.
So we're obviously addressing
that explicitly in the policy.
Remember, the policy is about dos and
don'ts, and if it is copyrighted
material or there's intellectual
property, how that should be handled.
Of course, it talks about that.
Interestingly, it also talks
about export controls.
While universities have people
from all over the world, and
people work with counterparts in
other countries and things like that,
when there's exchange of things across
national boundaries, of course,
export control becomes an issue.
And that's why it's interesting that
it sort makes its way into this policy.
But again, this is sort of
the guiding principle here,
is that there are any legal
requirements we are okay with them.
Georgia Tech's policy actually also,
remember one of the things we said,
we have to make sure that
the people who responsible for
it can be held accountable and
things like that.
So it does address responsibility for
securing the resources or
the assets that we have, and
it's kind of a distributed
responsibility at Georgia Tech.
When you look at sort of the larger
network Office of Information Technology
which is a central organization for
the entire university,
well they're responsible for it.
But if you look at individual devices,
laptops, servers, or desktops, all
that is the responsibility of the unit
or the individual whose machine it is.
A unit for example,
School of Computer Science or
the College of Computing, for
example, would be responsible for
the computers that are used by
their staff, faculty, and students.
But protecting the Georgia Tech
network that is the responsibility of
the central office.
As I said,
you should read the policy and
all the different aspects
that are covered by it.